oh welcoming into the studio now Cedric
the Entertainer how are you he's got a
novel out man you are you're you're
you're I'm out here you know reading for
rainbow for the kids yeah do you have to
be able to read to write yeah I think so
but you know now we got audio books now
so a lot of times it's just like talking
to the kids like like a substitute
teacher just dictate you're dictating
someone else writes it down yeah exactly
that's it that's the that's the new
world of uh book writing for sure when
you're do you you feel any type of way
about audio books like does it bother
you at all that you're slaving away for
the you know the written page and the
idea that someone's like um I don't know
if I'll go all the trouble to read it
but I'll put it on in the car but you
know that actually that's been the way I
I like to ride to work now like so I
listen to a lot of audio books which
makes me think I'm a great reader so I
say that a lot oh I read that book
that's it's a complete lie no you did
read the book that's the thing we we
knock ourselves and we go ah I didn't
read it but you listen to I think that's
smarter I think you're an idiot if you
sit there with a book in front of you
you're much smarter if you walk
somewhere and you listen to it you think
that's smarter you're absorbing the
information you know and then you know
like you know how people go like I'm
going to take a book with me on vacation
and sit there and read the book I'm
sleep in anytime I read anything two P
two and a half pages I'm sleep I'm the
same way or like you're you realize like
halfway down the page I have no idea
what got go I got to go
back why a novel did you always want to
do it or did somebody suggest
no you know this was something that you
know I would hear these family stories
about my grandfather and then just like
you know like any great tale you start
to imagine everything else that went
around it and so that's exactly you know
he passed before I was born but when I
would think about him I I could just
visualize his whole day so that made me
wanted to like just kind of create a
world around who he was and so that's
what I started to do I just you know I
had small stories that I can only
imagine everything else that happened
happened and so that that allowed me to
bring him to life in my mind and you
know and in this story so it's great and
I I can do it all the time so I kind of
write I wrote this in the sense that it
could be serial we can have like more
books if we wanted to you just kind of
fell in love with like this is the
character about the character and it
takes place in like the depression right
around then yeah right right right right
after World War II uh it's late it's
more it's like 48 1948 that area yeah
what did your family do when you were a
kid yeah they so my grandmother and my
grandfather had a restaurant they used
to have a restaurant it was a riverb
city uh you know where back then too it
was you know was wasn't a lot of
interstat so people actually used the
river to get up and down the country and
especially the Mississippi and so these
little small towns actually had you know
a lot of energy to them uh but they had
a restaurant they had like a you know a
small like kind of hotel for uh you know
the the the the black musicians that
would come stay in this town uh then my
grandfather was also a bootlegger and so
you get all that in the book because
they moved liquor him and the and the
sheriff they were friends and so I added
all of these things to the storytelling
to put him in a a a crime Caper
situation so it's it's dope the book is
fun did you go to any older relatives
and talk to them about like hey what was
he like or what was this like people
that are that remember him yeah mainly
mainly you know his kids my mom and my
uncle those were the ones it was a
couple of people around like again uh uh
may it was one lady that knew a little
bit she kind of gave me like the his
friend group and some of the other
things he did but that was it like most
of the people that were around when he
was around they were all gone everybody
had passed by the time I started to you
know really do the research on this book
and you look back like a I had all
those people I could have asked
questions to and I didn't I didn't think
of it while they were here man that's
the acknowledg I put it in the back of
the book more than anything I definitely
want to encourage people because we've
just gotten to a space where we don't
really know like our relatives like that
I was saying my kids they probably know
like four to six of their cousins I grew
up knowing 30 20 cousins like you know
you know your whole family you spend
time together uh but you know now you
know you know one or two of your your
relatives and and so go back man you got
if you got Elders in your family talk to
them you'll find out a lot about who you
are you'll be surprised some of the the
habits you have these things exist in
your family before you know and and even
dreams and aspirations that question of
like what did my family do like these
things you start to understand like why
I have so many Educators in my family my
my grandmother was a you know like a she
taught the local kids and you know was a
midwife and did these things and now my
mother became a teacher now my sister's
a teacher so education is like kind of
running our family and then on the men's
side everybody was kind of like Hustlers
and and dreamers and people wanted to do
bigger things nobody wanted to have a
job they and not not like Street
Hustlers but this aspiration that they
had that entrepreneurial energy that
kind of comes from my grandfather so is
that why you're always trying like new
things CU you've done yeah everything
like sitcom work movie work standup
reality show writing like it's like
whatever wherever there's a lane to go
down it feels like that's the one that
you're like yeah I can I I can do that
let me put put everything into it yeah
man definitely you know I wish I was
born as a athlete too because I would
have tried to do that you know
but but but it is that idea of like
anything that I you know I feel like is
is doable for me I'm going to try it and
so you know and I've been feel I've been
very blessed to be able to do that
Broadway move like you say stand up
sitcoms movies dramas you know even do a
little bit drama roles here and there um
you know so I just want to continue on
that path and and try to be an example
in that way that people just you don't
have to put yourself in the Box even if
the town wants to put you in the Box
don't believe you have to be in it and
don't sell yourself short about being an
athlete cuz yeah I'm a WWE Fan I saw you
get the r you saw that I mean I saw you
I saw you get in the ring a while main
about the shorts in the cape that's that
was that was really it was really an
outfit Choice what I was going for there
well it was a really interesting era
because it was like at a time when WWE
was bringing a lot of celebrities in
yeah to do stuff week to week and as
somebody who watches week to week you
could always Spot the Difference like
some celebrities would come in and just
put nothing in and it sucked and it was
like they didn't want to be there you
could tell and then other celebrities
would come in and they do go hard
everything and it felt like you made
that conscious decision like if we're
doing this we grew up in that era where
wrestling was really like fun to watch
too I think you know and that was one of
the things that I remember like in St
Louis they used to have a whole thing
called wrestling at the Chase and and
the wrestlers would come and so you know
you knew these guys and so that idea of
giving them a show when you walk out and
being a villain you know you got to lock
into to that part man the you believed
it by the way it was believable that's
so true my father took me to as a kid I
remember Sergeant Slaughter walking
through and I remember wanting to spit
on him I was a kid I didn't do it but I
remember just thinking like I got to
spit on him and I just I just knew was
would have been a bad move I was
probably like 11 years old but you
really you bought into it when you were
a kid yeah yeah mean you had the Chic
and Tojo Yamamoto look at that he would
you would be canceled you can't call it
Moto anymore but that was the goal right
you would want people to show up and
want to stab somebody yeah exactly right
like you'd show up with weap people
would show up with weapons weapons and
because they wanted to stab Tojo
mamoto Andre the Giant yeah how did they
uh how did the guys there react to you
going like yeah I want to go all the way
in were they like very welcoming when
they found that out no they did you know
that was the thing about it you know
they that the you know that's the what
the raw Friday Night Raw I think that
was the big one Monday Night Raw raw
yeah was like that but they want to put
on a good show so you know like and I
had a guy that was like my double you
know like so that he was going to take
all the like Falls and everything the
real Falls and he was just what do you
want me to do you want you what what do
you want to do do you like a guy that
want to look like you got thrown over
the Rope I'm like yes
yes I'm not going to actually be the one
but you're going to do it for me as my
double yes throw me over the road wait
they bring a double in in front of the
audience it's yeah they it's weird they
slide them out somehow like and then you
know they they do the work it's it's
they do but and there's a live audience
there they they're right there but how
it's wrestling man they nobody knows
it's just like real wrestling you can
look at it and go
a and it's not him but they believe we
get it's a show yeah it's who car I get
on the ground he get get thrown around
then I go and lay
down he guy gets on top of me counts me
out and then I flip him over and then I
win yeah boom you get to walk out with
the
w the crowd booze me like yeah and I'm
trying to get called back next week for
being the new villain what's the hardest
out of all those things that you like
Sam writing stand up act what's the
hardest for you out of all those I think
you know for me it was definitely
writing this novel because it was just
one of these things where like um you
know you got to keep the plot you you
need to keep like Theory Al where you
going you know you have to do that in
standup too you know where you if you
start a joke especially if it's one that
you end up calling back a couple of
times you got to really know the the
point but that's something that I feel
like we end up doing naturally as
standups you you just kind of find your
rhythm in the way you tell a joke but
then but in the book you know it's it's
story it's plot points it's things that
you got to satisfy for readers you know
and so uh that became a little you know
that's where you have to kind of dig
deep and and do a lot more work that's
probably the toughest one that in um the
time I did Broadway because Broadway is
another one where the playright the
words that they wrote is the most
important thing you don't have the
ability to kind of like jump off the
page and do it yourself or improv a
moment or just trust your natural
instinct especially you like again as
comedians you just like yo sometime a
moment of happen I just go freestyle you
can't do that on Broadway or acknowledge
when it's bad like if something go wrong
the best part of stand you could
acknowledge it and and make it okay and
make it funny but actors on Broadway
just looks terrifying because if it's if
it's bombing or if it's wrong you just
you have to live at it you yeah exactly
you just ride it out that's it man so
that was a tough one it was smart and
then I you know I did it with John le
was and and Haley Joe Osman so people
that were really Pro actors so so it was
a good space and I look forward to doing
that again but that was probably the
toughest you know like experience of of
like indiv visual growth if you will
like in doing something entertaining
wise how was game show hosting yeah I
had more I had fun game show hosting you
know I mean the big the big thing was
you know is that you do so many shows in
the day people don't know like you're
knocking them down like five shows in a
row like you so after a while you know
people think that you're really smart
because you see the answers but it just
goes out like soon as they say rap I
couldn't tell
you I couldn't tell you one survey said
when you're watching uh uh the shows
back can you tell when you're okay that
was the fifth in a line like can you
tell on your face like oh I was dying I
was dying definitely yeah like I'm not
even wearing a hat
anymore tot I'm totally just like
sitting there like yeah yeah yeah come
on bring it on Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire that everybody does don't
you how long did you do it uh I did it
for one season and uh it was it was
great we shot it here and then they were
they were moving it to Connecticut um
and I was like I'm good yeah it seems
like once you get into the RH we were
talking about Drew carry the other day
once you're in the rhythm of doing five
or six a day it's probably a great gig
because you work a couple times a month
yeah but not if you have to go to
Connecticut yeah yeah yeah you know cuz
I saw I saw I saw Drew Carrey not too
long ago we did like the the you know
the celebrity version of it and you're
right he was very content and I I
thought after his success of his TV show
and you know in a cool standup that he
would not love that job for as long as
he's been doing it but you're right once
you kind of get into it you get that
Rhythm it's like hey man yeah just get
this big check and I'm good I got an
easy schedule I'm done on Thursday at
like 4 o' that only do I not have to
come up with jokes I shouldn't come up
with jokes just stand there and he and
he can do stand up if he wants to he
wants to go on the road that's how you
know Cedric is doing well though like it
was a great gig but what happened G GW
Bridge I'm not going the GW Bridge it's
not doing it
exactly no that's so true I'm not
driving yeah I'm not driving that's
ridiculous no way I'm not doing that
that's what it's a whole Bridge you got
to go over are you here or West Coast
I'm West Coast I'm uh I'm Los Angeles
base um you know I've been out there
since uh like 94 I'm from St Louis
originally then my wife is a California
girl and that's it once you they don't
move California Girls when uh when
Lee came to you guys originally yeah and
said look let's make a movie out of this
tour yeah did you believe it was well
you know the thing was is that the tour
had been going and so we actually had an
opportunity to pick Spike Lee so you
know so he it was we we were the ones
doing the tour and then many people came
but Spike was of course you know he was
the guy that was you know can you know
represent the culture and shooting in a
way that we knew would give us that that
you know that that kind of credence that
we needed and so of of course he loved
it he came and saw us perform live a
couple of different places loved the
world Lov you know loved to laugh and so
we knew that he he was the right person
to shoot that movie man and did you was
it always like this is a theatrical
movie We're making not a comedy special
yeah yeah that was the whole thing about
having like that kind of director was to
shoot it like a movie yes and so you
know and you know Kings of Comedy
literally has some of the longest legs
of a you know of a movie like that that
still works it still gets a lot of play
yeah people love it when they see it and
you know even though suits are a little
dated for sure yeah sure sure sure
Styles change but that's the kids what
do they know these kids don't know
anything we wore 18 buttons back there
it's going to take me big deal jackets
were a little longer how we wore
them it was a was a cloak jacket what I
had to get off my horse and carriage was
it pure standup or was there backstage
and and other things or was just the
whole thing was just stand up no it was
all stand up but then we did we showed
backstage we showed us you know like
kind of hanging out tour bus stuff uh
you know it was a couple of really fun
scenes there they showed me like in the
dressing room getting ready uh the
warm-ups and all that kind of things so
that that movie is like really fun but
that but it was really a standup movie
but done you know film style but the
fact that it was a theatrical movie I
think for a lot of people they probably
weren't exposed to standup comedy at all
because no when that came out it's like
it was like nowadays standup is
everywhere it's all over the Internet
it's all over everything but I don't
know when that movie came out how much
standup I had actually seen yeah but you
see this trailer you're like yeah I'm
GNA I'm going to go see that movie
you're like oh this is this is kind of
that first exposure to you know 90
minutes of of pure standup and it was
funny because people had done it was it
had been a few Arena tours before us but
and I think even even like Eddie
Murphy's raw may have been prior did
live in concert was
release uh so uh but you know like this
was that group of people kind of like a
Superfest or like a Coachella kind of
thing right where you saw your favorites
all together that that that idea hadn't
really been done in comedy so that was
that that was really special we had a
blast doing it and U you know just one
of those things I don't know if you can
put it back in the bottle people always
yeah can you do it again you know and
it's like and plus Bernie Mack is pass
and it's it wouldn't even feel right
doing it without B ma we guys doing like
25 minutes each something like that 30
like 30 minutes each come on man go on
and do 30 minutes in front of a packed
Arena just kill and then you can switch
it like each night you don't necessarily
that's the thing about it you know cuz
we'll work on an hour you'll have a lot
of material but then you know when you
have a compacted set where you just just
know that you literally walk out and
just hit you with bombs
B good night you like and how often do
you have a tour like that where everyone
blows up from it it's not like that was
a vehicle in my case
never and you're by yourself yeah you go
like how it I blow up do you mean
implode yeah you go full Submariner uh
no but I mean like it it's not like that
was a vehicle for one of you guys
everyone yeah went skyh high after that
yeah man that and it's so great I mean
actually I did my charity tournament and
Steve and DL was there like that was
like about three weeks ago and the fact
that we hadn't really all been together
in so long it was just really special to
have that that that Ste that Bond but
everybody's doing their thing you know
Steve de myself everybody's having a
great time doing it and of course you
know Bernie had that TV show and and
would be out of here if he was still
around you know he was just one of those
guys we just talking about how that's so
interesting like uh in this new new
socially politically correct Council
culture like a lot of that stuff
wouldn't work you know like true like
that whole some of those jokes would be
like no sorry we got to pull that one
but there is something about the fact
that Bernie has has passed but his work
is here that there are still new fans
yeah that are finding it now and they
can't cancel it if they try right so
it's like well I guess you got to just
like that's who he was that's a lot yeah
but also when you're doing those jokes
in arenas it makes it harder for people
to say like when dice got in trouble
like it was like you're in an arena and
there's 18,000 people laughing it's
really hard there's a lot of people
enjoying it it's hard for anyone to go
oh that's that's offensive there's
that's so true because when you're in
the comedy club it's so right there and
and people can they it can Trickle and
and they got a opportunity to yell back
at you but in like you're right in a in
in a big arena like you know it's the
jokes are hitting you and and you're
trying to keep it going so so you know
but right now we do we we're in a
business where you know being
very acutely aware of what you're saying
in a joke is something you have to kind
of take you know you have to really take
that account you can't just be free to
like let something come out of your
mouth because you you got an idea that
you think this might be funny which is
why it's a good time to be a writer yes
and the book no it's not
strike I a novelist no good time to be a
novelist uh flipping box cars the debut
novel from Cedric the Entertainer uh
releases today go out there and get it
he's doing a book signing uh tomorrow at
Barnes & Noble on 5th and 46th and
newerk too right 12 p.m. tonight yes yes
at uh the Newark Symphony Hall tonight
uh he'll be in conversation so get there
Newark at Symphony Hall classic yeah it
really does sound very conversation with
Cedric a gentleman's
evening and then uh also uh signing at
Barnes & Noble uh at the Grove in Los
Angeles Thursday at 7 p.m. uh and then
there's a couple more in conversations
happening in Santa Monica in St Louis
you can go to IM
[Music]
cedric.core.symantec.com it's a great
thing man absolutely we'll see you guys
tomorrow
y